thank you to nebula and curiositystream
for sponsoring this video bonus content
alongside this video is available ad
free on nebula
at the start of 2020 we all got used to
a view like this government officials
and scientists took to the stage to
announce that a pandemic was spreading
throughout the world things aren't too
bad right now in our country they'd say
but expect things to get worse over the
next couple of weeks as the virus
spreads if we take decisive action right
now though we could prevent the virus
from getting out of control we still see
things get worse for a time but if we
hold our nerve we'll reduce the
suffering overall and we can get back to
our lives this report is much the same
prior to this news conference there were
five others of increasingly certain
increasingly stern warnings but the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change working group 1 assessment report
6 to give it its full title released in
august 2021 feels to me the most like an
early pandemic press conference in the
eight years since the last report enough
cases have occurred enough evidence has
built up that there really can no longer
be any doubt that we are on the verge of
something
serious the only difference is that it's
going to be playing out over decades and
centuries rather than hopefully just a
couple of years in fact just in case
you're not going to make it through this
whole video let me shrink that time
scale down even further and summarize it
in four bullet points climate change
right now is like the pandemic was
towards the start in the things aren't
terrible right now they're not great but
they're not that bad
but they will get worse in the immediate
future
we really want to avoid the really bad
stuff that will happen if we do nothing
about this situation which is going to
be very bad indeed
but
if we take action
now decisively and with full force we
can avoid a potential catastrophe
right
let's talk about that in a bit more
detail i'm mostly going to talk at the
level of the summary for policy makers
in this video for some accessible
reporting on the technical summary which
is one step more complicated go to the
ever excellent carbon brief for their
coverage linked below the ipcc report
summarizes what we know to date the
things aren't going that good humans
have increased the concentration of
various greenhouse gases in the earth's
atmosphere and this has caused the
earth's surface temperature to increase
on average by one degree celsius though
there's a significant deviation from
that number depending on where exactly
you are
at the same time extremely hot weather
has become more frequent and more
intense and where there's enough
information to say we think that extreme
precipitation events so heavy rainfall
for example has become more frequent and
more intense
these factors combined have led to a
situation where extreme events like
drought and famine have become more
likely and events that are so extreme
we've never even seen them before have
also become more likely that's what
we're living through right now but of
course that's not all most of the report
is concerned with what further changes
the climate is going to experience in
the future
some of which we are already locked into
committed to because of our actions to
date but most of which depend on what we
do now and in the immediate future
perhaps not surprisingly there's a lot
of bad news in this section but i am
pleased to say i think there's some
positive news hiding in there too the
report sets out visions of the future
called shared socioeconomic pathways or
ssps these represent possible societal
responses to climate change ranging from
the optimistic cutting emissions very
quickly and removing lots of carbon from
the atmosphere in the late century to
the realistic cutting emissions slowly
or barely at all to the worst case
scenario each of these scenarios has a
variety of expected impacts associated
with them though there are commonalities
between the different scenarios
generally speaking we expect a
phenomenon to occur in response to the
globe warming but the intensity of that
phenomenon that response increases as
the global warming increases in value so
a world that's warmed by three degrees
will see the same changes as a world
that's warmed by two degrees just more
intensely the main takeaway from this is
that the observed changes we've seen in
temperature and precipitation and
extreme events will intensify as the
planet continues to warm so each
additional degree of warming brings with
it more and more extreme changes more
and more extreme conditions but not
uniformly so in temperature specifically
for example we expect some parts of the
world to warm by over three times the
global average so while there may be a
global warming of say three degrees
celsius some parts of the world will
warm by over nine degrees the ipcc
actually built a great interactive tool
allowing you to see how this will play
out worldwide i'll link that below
but as well as that main takeaway of
intensifying effects that we've already
seen there are some incredibly
concerning secondary effects hidden in
these pages that we haven't seen just
yet but we probably will in the coming
years to talk about them i called on a
friend of mine from when i was doing my
phd professor matt collins who's a
professor in climate change at the
university of exeter and the met office
matt's worked extensively with the ipcc
before including on the last assessment
report ar5 one of his main research
interests is the el nino southern
oscillation or enso and its expected
impact in a warming world is one of the
most troubling things to me in this
report el nino events are associated
with dry monsoon years and that's the
you know that that is a considerable
um of considerable importance
agriculture in india particularly in
in the plains wheat and rice you know
fairly stable crops actually having
won one bad year followed by one good
year followed one by one bad year which
might be a sort of scenario obviously if
you see an increase in energy
variability could be pretty devastating
in a warmer world we can among other
places expect the indian subcontinent to
receive increasingly variable amounts of
rainfall and no agricultural technology
on earth is going to be able to overcome
the challenge of repeated drought years
so as the world warms we can expect the
global food supply and perhaps
specifically the food supply in a place
where a billion people currently live to
become increasingly precarious one of
the other incredibly worrying things
highlighted in this report is the
possibility of irreversible changes
things that we've already set in motion
in the natural world through our
emissions to date and now
can't be undone so things like ice
sheets are impacted by the
by the radiation forcing but also by the
ocean warming
and that ocean warming is something
which has a very long time scale there's
a big inertia in the system there so
any imbalance in the radiative
forcing of the atmosphere now will be
felt in the ocean for many hundreds of
years
so that's that's the that's the kind of
worry when it comes to ice sheets you
can have this destabilizing effect of
the ocean water going underneath the ice
sheets irreversible of course is a
definitive thing but really irreversible
for climate time scales means
irreversible in the next few hundred
years unless you're talking about
something like the green and ice sheet
or the antarctic ice sheet which could
be really irreversible
there's a variety of points like this in
the report and yes we should be very
concerned about them but i don't want to
lead you to despair because i do think
that amongst all of this bad news there
are a few bits of good news buried in
there as well first of all we have a
much better idea of what we're up
against i mean that broadly but
specifically the report gives a tighter
estimate of what's called the earth's
ecs or equilibrium climate sensitivity
this is how much warming we'd expect to
see eventually after doubling the amount
of co2 in the earth's atmosphere what's
really happened is that the the lower
bound
has sort of snuck up a bit so it was you
know maybe 1.5 degrees and maybe it's
now two to five degrees and i think
that's really been
associated with a huge piece of work
done by people on cloud feedbacks
and
really kind of trying to nail down what
those the uncertainties associated with
quantum feedbacks and seeing that those
are
you know client feedbacks are
essentially positive
and the idea of having negative client
feedbacks or even components apply
feedback to a negative is now kind of
not really considered to be physically
reasonable
that might not sound like good news
after all it might be a slightly higher
climate sensitivity but with smaller
error bars we better know the enemy
we're fighting and we know how much
warming to expect for a given amount of
emissions so we can modify our plans for
reducing emissions accordingly far
better news is this paragraph stating
that one of the biggest potential
tipping points in the climate the
atlantic meridional overturning
circulation or amok which is a conveyor
belt of water in the atlantic is
unlikely to flip into a different very
weak state but instead we can somewhat
and then gradually recover contrary to
what one very well publicized recent
paper found this is good news as if the
amok were to switch off which could be
very sudden then the northern hemisphere
would sharply cool and become drier as
well as experiencing a likely cataclysm
for marine species which would be felt
through the whole biosphere so we think
that's not going to happen which is good
news another famous climate tipping
point that we also think is unlikely to
be reached is the release of greenhouse
gases like methane from the permafrost
in places like siberia the fear was that
global warming would melt the permafrost
in these places and release those
greenhouse gases causing a huge amount
of extra warming but it appears very
unlikely that that's going to happen
this century which is very good news
though matt did have a word to say on
this i i still think that that research
is pretty
difficult to do because of modeling
these things and also
it's a difficult place in the world to
take observations
you know being up in the siberian tundra
in winter
it's not really my idea as a modeler of
the sort of science i want to do that's
a job for a phd student
perhaps the most positive takeaway from
this report is that we are still not
committed to catastrophic climate change
in the end of three or four degrees
celsius because the report highlights
that what ultimately matters is the
cumulative amount of carbon in the
atmosphere the total amount of carbon
that we've put up there for all
activities that means that if we can get
our act together now really put the
brakes on emissions and lower the total
cumulative amount of carbon that will
end up in the atmosphere
we can avoid a future with frequent
extreme
droughts and floods and famines and
wildfires it's not too late
but every year that we delay doing
something about it we make the problem
worse in the end when i asked matt what
the most shocking thing in this report
was to him
he said this
so if you look at the bottom of the or
almost the last page of the summer of
the policymakers there's a section about
allowable emissions to avoid uh
different levels of global warming so
we've talked a lot about
what's been a lot of talk about 1.5
degrees and 2 degrees and if you look at
some of the numbers in that table
you know we're talking a few hundred
gigatons of carbon now we're currently
emitting around 30 to 40 gigatonnes of
carbon so we could be looking at
you know
only 10 years before we're basically
gonna cross 1.5 degrees or be committed
to crossing 125 degrees
our response to the global pandemic
gives us a window into how we'll likely
respond to climate change
people it turned out were resilient they
were and society in general was
capable of making huge changes to
respond to a dire threat
the way we lived our lives changed we
listened to the experts heeded their
warnings took action and eventually
saw the situation improve
but
i'm sure i'm not the only person who
looks back at these early press
conferences and feels frustrated in
those crucial early days of the pandemic
decisions were made that had long
lasting consequences
politicians pre-barricaded they
hesitated and only took action
reluctantly and often on too small a
scale
and because of this the worst fears of
some epidemiologists were realized and a
catastrophic
costly both monetarily and in human
lives pandemic erupted across the world
had decisive action been taken early
globally this wouldn't have happened
there would have been a short-term cost
absolutely but it pales in comparison to
the long-term damage we suffered instead
let's not make that mistake again at
this press conference the facts are
clear things aren't too bad right now
but if we don't take action
now
we're going to be looking down the
barrel of a far
far greater threat than coronavirus
every year that we delay taking action
the worse it's going to be
please
don't ignore
this warning
let's get it right this time
matt was extremely generous with his
time and i was able to ask him a whole
bunch of questions about this topic some
of which i was asking on behalf of my
supporters on patreon matt's answers to
those questions covering machine
learning in climate science and carbon
neutrality by 2050 and much more are
available right now on nebula you've
almost certainly heard of nebula before
the streaming service owned by a huge
collection of educational youtubers
including me here we upload additional
content that wouldn't play nicely with
the youtube algorithm as well as
original content such as better
elevation a series about how we approach
video production and neo's fascinating
tragic the unknown city unlike youtube
nebula has no adverts anywhere on its
pages or in its videos instead you pay a
subscription fee that gets split between
creators directly supporting our
educational work and resulting in a
better viewing experience for you except
you can get completely free access to
nebula if you sign up to our partners
curiositystream the home of the best
documentaries on the internet and why
wouldn't you be interested in doing that
if you've watched this video this far
you clearly care about the natural world
and so would love the thousands of
documentaries on curiosity stream from
david attenborough's light on earth to
seasons of the forest for more
information about climate change you
could check out any number of super high
quality documentaries they have on the
subject if nebula is the best of small
scale individual productions curiosity
stream is the best of big budget
professional productions it's the
perfect combination then to get both in
a bundle which if you go to
curiositystream.com simon clark link
below you can do for 26
off that's only
14.79 for a year's access to all of this
and all of this
it's possibly the best investment you'll
ever make in your online viewing and in
supporting educational video online like
this thank you to curiositystream and to
nebula for sponsoring this video
thank you for watching the video i hope
that you enjoyed it if
enjoy is really the right word i have no
doubt that i'll be making more videos
about this report in the future but if
you'd like to see some of my previous
videos on topics in climate change then
you can check some of them out up here
thank you again for watching and
i'll see you in the next one